لا يعميك الغضب، لكن دعني أطلب
منك ألا يستهلكك الغضب، لأن
ما يصنع الفارق بين
المجتمع المتحضر والجماعة الإرهابية
هو احترام
حياة الإنسان، يا رئيس الوزراء، هل أنت مرتاح لذلك،
هل تعتقد أن الغضب أمر طبيعي؟
عامل تحفيز كبير هنا وهل أنت
مرتاح لنسبة
الموت التي تحدث في غزة
الآن انظر انظر الغضب هو نوع طبيعي جدًا
من الغريزة في البشر وأه
بطريقة ما هو نتيجة التطور
والحاجة إلى البقاء  في
البيئات القاسية في نفس الوقت أكرر
ما قلته أن الدم المغلي
ليس دليلاً جيدًا
لأغراض أه استراتيجية
والأصوات الأخرى التي سمعتها
تعني فقط أن كبار السن يقدمون
نصائح ذكية للصغار  أه،
ولكن بعد أن قلت إنني يجب أن أخبركم
أننا نبذل قصارى جهدنا،
نشعر بالالتزام الكامل بالقانون الدولي،
ونلتزم تمامًا بمبدأ
التناسب هذا، فنحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا، نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا
مرارًا وتكرارًا في
كل مكان سنهاجمه
و  أوصي جميعنا بالنظر
إلى السلسلة السببية التي أدت إلى
وفاة أشخاص على الجانب الإسرائيلي، حيث تم
تنفيذ المذبحة على يد هؤلاء
الإرهابيين البرابرة في منطقة شرق غزة أم
غزة، وقد تم ارتكابها من قبل
نفس الإرهابي في مكان مختلف.  وقاموا
بوضع مسدس على صدغ هؤلاء
المدنيين ومنعوهم من التحرك إلى
المكان الآمن في الجانب الجنوبي من قطاع
غزة، مما أدى إلى
احتجازهم كدرع بشري، متعمدين
علمهم التام بما يفعلونه.
لا أرى طريقة لإعفائهم
من المسؤولية عن فقدان
الزوجة، فنحن لا نستطيع أن نمنح
حماس حصانة من العقاب بمجرد السماح
لهم بتوجيه شعبهم نحو
المسدس لحمايتهم، لذا دعني
أسألك  هذا إذا كنت أعلم أن هذا هو
موقف
الحكومة، فهل يمكنك أن تخبرني إذن كيف
يمكن للمرء أن يبرر موقف
الحكومة الحالية ورئيس الوزراء الحالي
الذي، كما نعلم من
المواد مفتوحة المصدر، ينقل كلماته الخاصة، في
الواقع، أخبرني، أخبرني  أنا لأنك كنت
هناك كيف كانت لديه استراتيجية
لحماس في G،
أخبرنا
انظر، لقد قلت مرارًا وتكرارًا يمكنني أن
أكررها هنا باللغة الإنجليزية ولكني أقولها
أيضًا بالعبرية وكان لدى نان
خطأ فادح بشأن الاستراتيجية جيدًا.
قبل خمس سنوات، سيقول لك بعض الناس أنه منذ
أكثر من خمس سنوات، قام بصياغة
استراتيجية كما حددها. ومن يريد
التأكد من أننا نستطيع منع أي
احتمال
لحل الدولتين عليه أن يدعم
موقفي المتمثل في إبقاء حماس
قوية وركلية.  وعلى قيد الحياة،
كان مستعدًا لرشوتهم
بأموال الحماية التي تأتي نقدًا
من قطر، ولإضعاف
السلطة الفلسطينية وليس
العكس، وأنا أنتمي إلى حوالي
نصف الجمهور في إسرائيل الذين يعتقدون
أن هذين الاثنين  حل الدول هو
الحل الوحيد القابل للتطبيق على المدى الطويل،
ربما لا يكون هذا هو الوقت الأبيض مرة أخرى
لأن شخصين لا يزالان
مدفوعين بغريزة الغضب
والدم المغلي ولكن أصبحنا
نعتقد بقوة أن هذا هو
الخيار الوحيد القابل للتطبيق ليس بسبب  العدالة
للفلسطينيين، وهي ليست
أولويتي القصوى ولكنها أولوية
مبررة بالنسبة لهم، وذلك بسبب
الضرورة الملحة بالنسبة لنا نحن إسرائيل
من أجل حماية أمننا
ومستقبلنا وهويتنا الخاصة التي نحتاجها
للحصول على هذين الاثنين  - حل الدولة
وأعتقد بقوة أنه يمكن
رسم خط ديل داخل
الأرض الموعودة والذي سيكون لدينا فيه 80% من
المستوطنين وكل
مصلحتنا الإستراتيجية وسيمتد كل ذلك على
عدد من النسب المئوية من
المساحة الإجمالية لدولة  الضفة الغربية أه أن نعيش
جنبا إلى جنب مع دولة فلسطينية منزوعة السلاح ولكن
قابلة للحياة تسيطر على
هذا الجزء من قطاع غزة
وهذا الجزء من الغرب وقطاع غزة
ونحتاجها
لمستقبلنا ولكن ليس سرا أن
أكثر قليلا من نصف
الجمهور الإسرائيلي أه يشعرون أن الرؤية العظيمة هي
دولة واحدة أعتقد أنها كارثة لكننا
دولة ديمقراطية لذلك علينا
إقناعهم بعدم إكراههم
وهذا تحدي كبير خاصة
بعد 7 أكتوبر  عندما
يحفز الحدث بعض الناس للذهاب حتى إلى
المزيد من التطرف في المطالبة بالانتقام ويعتقد
البعض منهم أنه لا توجد وسيلة
للبقاء على قيد الحياة في الشرق الأوسط إلا إذا
اعتمدت هذه
القواعد البربرية الهمجية وبالطبع هؤلاء مجرد
أقلية ضئيلة ولكن  في الأساس، ليس من السهل
إقناع الجمهور الإسرائيلي بعد السابع من تشرين الأول (أكتوبر)
بأن حل الدولتين لا يزال هو الحل
الوحيد القابل للتطبيق على المدى الطويل.